they want answers
and those they say are responsible
called to account
[Applause]
many of these protesters blame Libya's
Eastern Administration for the flood
disaster in Turner they want to know how
two dams burst leading to the deaths of
thousands of people with many more
missing and feared dead they accused the
administration of corruption and
negligence we pray that all of the Dead
will rest in peace and I hope that this
is the end of our catastrophes we just
ask that if there's any rebuilding
effort that no Libyan company be ever
involved this is because everyone in
derna from the head of the municipality
to all of the officials are corrupt
donor should either be left as is or a
foreign company should be involved The
Souls of the Dead will not be in vain
Libya has suffered Decades of political
violence and instability
the country has two rival
Administrations
construction experts say this
catastrophe could have been avoided had
the dams built in the 1970s been
properly maintained
Hassan kasar says the wall of water mud
and Rubble that crashed through this
city killed his four children
I'm all alone he cries and he will never
forget
people told me the water entered the
house and my children were inside and
their uncles kept telling them to come
out by they could not the Water started
flowing inside from the windows they
tried to exit from the back but the
water went in and forced them to float
to the ceiling and the four of them
drowned
the search for bodies goes on
identifying those recovered is difficult
because many are decomposed
threat of disease Rises every day
I'm looking for my brother-in-law his
daughter and his wife they went to that
yard there is no news about them
it's estimated that the homes of around
30 000 people were Swept Away
International assistance continues to
arrive
shock and grief among many of the
survivors is now turning into anger
rebuilding their city is a promise that
must be kept they say but if this
catastrophe could have been avoided
those responsible must pay
Charles Stafford Al Jazeera yeah